From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
I'm just going to record a little opening message just for the recording and then we'll start talking.
This is David Cline from Virginia Tech and the Southern oral history program.
Recording today for the Civil Rights History Project of the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
Today is the 1st of October 2013 and we have the pleasure of being in High Point, North Carolina today with Mr. Robert Brown.
Behind the camera is John Bishop of Media Generation and UCLA and we also have Elaine Nichols from the Museum here today too.
So I just want to start by saying thank you so much for making time in your schedule for us today.
Thank you for being here.
Yeah, absolutely.
And what I'd like to do, I know we have a lot of ground to cover.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
So if we could just start with your childhood or even before your childhood, if you like, talking about your family and your roots here, I think in this area, I think that'll be a great place to start.
Okay, I was born and raised here in High Point where I live now.
And my grandmother raised me, was born and raised in Anson County, that's down in Eastern North Carolina.
And her father, his name was Joseph Kimmel's senior, was a slave in that county down there.
And he was one of those who was used to help build the railroads in North Carolina because a lot of the labor building the railroads during that period was slave labor.
And interestingly enough, I became a number of years ago, 27 years ago, the Governor appointed me, Governor Jim Martin appointed me to be the president and CEO of the North Carolina Railroad Company, which the state owns the majority shares in now.
And the state owns all the shares in now.
It was like coming full circles.
Can I say was that four generations?
It's a full circle.
And so that's one of the other interesting things, interesting parts of my life that I had to happen.
But early on, my grandmother used to talk about the railroad because she was a maid up at the southern railroad station here in High Point.
And wherever we went, usually if the train went there, we would ride the train because she could get a discount on the tickets.
And so my brother now would go with her all over the place.
And so one day she came to us and said, you know, we're going to catch the bus.
We're going down to her home area called Wadesboro.
But we're going to go by way of Fayetteville North Carolina because there's something that I want you all to see.
And we were just small boys.
I mean, I was probably eight, nine years old.
My brother was 11 or 12.
And she said there's something I want you all to see.
And so we got on the bus and went with the Fayetteville North Carolina.
We were going to change buses there.
But there was a layover.
And my grandmother said, we're, come on, we're going to walk on down here.
And so she asked, got off the bus and we asked somebody, where is the old slave mart in Fayetteville?
And he fell and says, oh, you go down the street.
She's right down the road there.
So we walked around here.
And she said, I just wanted to bring you all here because this was the last place that my father was so.
Here in North Carolina was at that slave mart in Fayetteville.
And so it's the kind of thing you never really forget.
And my grandmother was a saint at Wormen who believed in God and believed in helping everybody and wanted to do something.
And she wanted her people to do something.
She wanted me and my brother and her son, my uncle and my mother, daughter, to really do some meaningful things.
And what did that do for you or to you seeing that place?
I think so.
It didn't do as much for me then as it did for me later.
And here I am all these years later.
I'm 77 years old.
And I was like eight or nine then.
And I was older up to understand what it was and so forth.
And my brother was two.
And the more I grew up and more I studied and I became steep in history.
History was my major subject.
It was my major in college in US history in particular.
And I wanted to know more.
I mean, he gave me an insatiable appetite to really get some base knowledge about.
History of America and history of slavery and reconstruction and all that.
So it peaked my interest as a young boy.
And I never forgot it.
Here I am all these years later.
Generations later.
Decades later.
Still talking about that trip.
And it was incredible.
And then we would go down to Wadesboro.
And we go down there, I have private two or three times a year to see her sisters.
They still lived on those farms and so forth.
And we would go by on several occasions.
We would go by to see the old house where my grandmother grew up.
It was an old clapboard place with no paint, a big old fireplace in there.
And it was run down and so forth.
And my grandmother would say, you know, we grew up here and we raised cotton and found out he owned a land.
And I would look at this place.
And it was incredible.
And then she say there was an old road, what they call a Rosenwald school.
And there was this old school building right there.
In the school building, I was down there a month and a half ago in that area.
And I went by there and this school building is still there and they're trying to renovate it a little bit now.
It's still standing all these years later.
So it really peaked my interest in history and what was going on and all of that.
What was your grandmother's name?
She was a child of the family in the L.I.E., Nelly Marshall Brown.
Her maiden name was Kendall, Nelly Marshall Brown.
Excuse me, second.
Thank you.
All right, so maybe we could talk a little bit about just growing up then here in High Point and what that was like in your school.
It was tough.
You were born in what year now?
I was born in 1935, February 1935.
And we were poor, difficult circumstances.
Everything was segregated.
There's certain water fountains you couldn't drink out of toilets.
If you went places, they had a toilet.
If they had a toilet for blacks, most of them did not have a toilet for blacks.
So they had a toilet, but you couldn't use them.
Because they had white toilet for men, white toilet for women.
But they had big signs up there, white.
So you knew right away.
But you know, there's a funny thing.
One of my favorite places, the shop, as a young boy and a young kid, was the Woolworth store.
Because they would have a variety of everything, unlike S.H. Kress, S.H. Kress, all of S.H. Kress and some of the others.
Woolworth would always seem to have good, holiday stuff and they'd have a variety of stuff.
So I like to go into the Woolworth store.
And my grandmother would take me to Woolworth store.
So in the back of the Woolworth store, there were the water fountains.
You had white water and you had colored water.
Over there, right over the fountain, you had white water and you had colored water.
So I mean, I'm just a little boy.
I don't know that much about the white water, colored water.
And I would be, you know, so one day I'm drinking out of the white water.
Because I just thought maybe the water was just had a little white in it or something.
And so my grandmother saw me.
She was already looking at something and I'm drinking water out of the white water.
And she turned around, saw me drinking out of white water.
And she came over there and she pulled me away from me.
And she said, boy, I don't drink there.
I have white water found in, I said, mama, she said, number water.
It just, it just tastes like the same water is the water over there, the color.
I said, I just want to see what the white water was like.
And she said, that's the same water sign.
It's just that people want you to drink out of the one, the color water.
And she said, one of these days, it'll be changed.
But right now we have to drink out of the white water and the color water.
So I said, well, my mother ate it the same water.
She said, oh, yeah, it's all God's water.
And she said, God's going to change it.
He's going to fix it after a while.
She said, I may not have left to see it, but he's going to fix it.
But thank God she lived to see that it was fixed.
And thank God she lived to see that I helped her fix it.
And amazingly, I helped her fix it on many sides.
Because when I went into business in 1961, in early 1961, my first major client was the F.W. Woolworth Co.
My first major client.
And in 1961, there was still color and white water in the South.
In 1961, there was still color and white toilets in 1961.
In 1962, 1963.
And we were became one of my major clients.
And I had, and I think they became a major client because I went to them and told them that they needed to change.
And that there was a change coming and they needed to get with it and have their thing stay in front of it so that they could remain a viable entity in America and eat in the world.
And they wanted to do that.
And they were, I found them interested in doing that.
And it amazed me.
But in a year and a half after I went to them and they hired me to do assessments around the country and to tell them what they ought to be doing in terms of their change in integrating and so forth across the country.
I was the principal advisor on all of this kind of thing, too, that company, it was one of the major companies in America.
And the people on their board of directors from the chairman on down were some of the major financiers in America.
John J. McCloy, who was the High Commissioner in Germany after World War II, the reconstruction.
He was one of the people on their board in the executive committee, Fred Kirby, who was chairman of the Allegheny Corporation, which was the predecessor of all these major hedge funds and all of that.
They owned a New York Central Railroad and a whole lot of other companies.
They were the biggest people financed years in America at that time.
And they were the ones who were responsible for setting policy and everything else at World War.
And so when I got to know them and I got to know what I was doing, they would invite me to their board retreats.
And to go off outings and so forth at the Westchester Country Club.
And I would be making presentations to their board of directors on the kinds of things they ought to be doing and what was happening in America and where we were going and that we needed to be in front of it, not behind it.
And they really believed what I told them. I was fascinated just by that.
And they began to tell me that there were other companies around in America who needed this kind of advice and counsel.
Other companies, many other companies, they controlled all that they were, big shareholders in.
And so they would send me to see other CEOs and chairman of board at this company and that company.
And I got a lot of business, a lot of clients just by following their advice and counsel on who I should go see.
And every time I go tell them that Mr. Kirby sent me all Mr. McCloy, who was the one of the biggest lawyers in America sent me.
So he told me to call you out.
Boom. I had another client immediately.
Well maybe we could back up for just a second and I'll back up a little bit further too.
But if you could tell us just a little bit about the company that you started and when you started it and why?
I started it. I started out as a policeman here in half-point.
Well maybe let's just back up a little bit further and then we'll catch up with that then.
So we were talking about your childhood. Maybe a little bit more about the school that you went to here.
I know that was very important for you and then you're a file.
So we'll take little breaks. We're back.
Well starting out, I started out as a little grade school, not too following my house called Leonard Street School.
I went to the sixth grade there and in the seventh grade all the classes for the black schools went to William Penn High School.
And so I went to William Penn High School which was a school that was founded by the Quakers who dominated the area in North Carolina.
And so I went there in the seventh grade and from then on and I graduated from there in the 12th.
But it was an extraordinary experience there because one of my first major experiences at William Penn was the principal came to me one day and he said,
you know, you're a bright young fella and it's something that I have for you to do and I ask him, yes sir, what is it?
He said, we have Mary McLeod Bethune coming to the school in the next few days.
And I want you to be on your best behavior because I want you to meet her at the door and stay with her and got her around the school all around the school and stay with her until she gets ready to leave.
And that afternoon and that's what I did. I met her at the door and Car came up with. I met her at the door told her who I was and that I was going to be her escort and I escort her around.
And she counseled me all that time for several hours. She would tell me. She asked me about my family about what I wanted to do with my life.
And then she said, you know, you're a bright young man. You're going to do some wonderful things at your life.
But she said, you've got to work hard. She said, you can't. You can't just come in here every day and run and play in everything. You just got to work at it.
And all the way through all day long, she would counsel me and tell me about her life. It was an extraordinary experience.
And that was one of my first real experiences in school that we had.
And then later on, we had people like Langston Hughes to come to the school, people like Dr. Delay Bogeau, who was a professor at Morehouse College, who had graduated for William Penn.
We had Colonel Smith, who became a Colonel in the Army, who had graduated for William Penn to come back and speak and so forth.
So we had a lot of interface with a great number of people who had graduated for William Penn and who had done extremely well to come back.
They would always come back and speak to the kids and do different things with us.
That's one of the things. It was a great experience. And I think that's so deceitful for me wanting to do things.
I was a voracious reader. I stayed in the library. The kids used to pick me up a lot of times. They said, oh man, you're going back to the library again.
I played football and stuff like that, just like other kids. But I was always reading something. I was always reading all the magazines and newspapers.
I want to know what was happening in the country and in the world.
So when I would go to the civics class or something like that, I would know a lot of things. By the time I was in the 10th and the 11th grade, I knew a lot.
I mean, I was up to date on all the current affairs of what was happening in the world. So I became, near the end of the 10th grade, I became the editor of our school paper.
And I think somewhere along the line, I have some of those papers now. And I go back and I read some of the editorials that I wrote as a 11th grade and 12th grade student.
Sometimes I don't believe that. I wrote that. It was in the 11th and 12th grade. But it was extraordinary. And I enjoyed it immensely.
Do you remember some of the things that you read back then? I think it's so interesting to think of being in a relatively small place like High Point, North Carolina. But you were really connecting out to a much larger world. And through some of these people that came to town.
I was reading all the time. First of all, I would read all the magazines, all the big magazines that would come in to the school in the school library. We didn't have money to get a lot.
So whatever came in the magazines in these papers. And then from time to time, we'd have the Sunday New York Times in there from time to time. And then we would have many of the local papers in there.
And I would go in because we didn't have money to get those papers and magazines where. So I'd go in there and I'd read everything in there. And then I'd read different books about what was happening in the world and different things.
So it was, but even more than that, there was a lady who lived across the street from us and they was Mrs. Loudon. And she worked for a wealthy white family. And one day I was sitting on the steps. And I had some old newspapers. I had maybe five or six newspapers that I was going through.
And I'd gotten from somewhere, probably got a mother garbage key because we didn't have money to get books. So newspapers and magazines. So I'd get them, I'd scrounge them up and I'd bring them home and I'd sit down and approach them and steps and read them.
So one day I'm reading these newspapers and so forth. And Mrs. Loudon comes home from work. And she sees me out there reading these newspapers and she stops and she says, Bobby, she said, I see you reading a lot. You love to read, don't you? I said, yes, ma'am.
She said, well, I throw away newspapers and magazines every month up there where I work. And sometimes two or three times a month. She said, they don't keep them. She said, if you'd like them, I'll bring them all home to you.
I said, oh, his members like his like to Lord himself was speaking to me. So for the next few years, she would about two or three times a month. She would bring a big box of newspapers and magazines.
And I mean, it'd be sometimes New York Times and magazines from New York and different kinds of magazines. And I would go through and I would read every one of them.
And so I became, I mean, I could go through a box of stuff and magazines and newspapers. And I found myself all these years later, I still read every day. I read several newspapers. I probably, in the course of any day, I'm at the end of the day. I probably have read
18 sometimes to a 15 newspapers from different parts of the country. I subscribe to newspapers from different parts of the country so that I will know what's happening in different places. And I will have some idea so that when I speak to different groups or I'm giving some thoughts, my thoughts on what's happening in different areas to my clients.
And then, you know, I'm giving it from a factual point of view. I'm not just pulling something out of the wind. And usually when I'm in a meeting, there's the board meeting, major cooperation that I might be in the board, or I might be giving a presentation. And they ask me questions.
And then, times out of ten, I'm going to know what I'm talking about. It's not going to be some theory that something I just looked up in the air and pulled down. You know, I'm going to know what is going on. And that's the way I've been since I was in high school.
And I was that way, I've been that way in business. I've been that way in different things, jobs that I've held. When I was at the White House.
When I would go out of meeting and do it. I had done not only reading, but I had different people who always sent me different kinds of information on different communities and places in the world of information.
And I still have those kind of contexts in Africa and Europe and different places around the world. So when I'm in a board meeting, I've served on a board of directors, some of the largest companies in the world.
And I still serve on a few. And when something comes up about one thing or another, I usually know something about it. I mean, I know the end depth phase of what had happened.
But I usually know something about it. And I can tell you sometimes why it happened here because it happened over there. And it made a trail over here. And it's happening here because somebody wanted that deal over here that happened.
So you know, you can put the dots together. But the only way you can do that is they have the knowledge base to do that. You can't do that on air. And I found that out a long time ago, you know, back in Haskell and Colin.
It's interesting that you see that because I was struck by that just reading about you in your career that you end up operating in this national, obviously, in international circles, but so rooted in the local.
And then coming back home to high point and staying in high point. So it's interesting for me to hear you say how important it is for you to understand what's happening at a very local level in the places where you were.
Yeah, because you know, when I go into a boardroom, when I go to make a presentation to a major group in New York, a London, a Paris or on, like those night years, you know, I know what I'm talking about.
And not only about red, but I've done a lot of background work. And so in after a while in having done it for decades, I can, I can watch the trends in the trends.
And what's the time do not lie, which you got to be able to understand what happened 25 or 30 years ago and how that's coming back into the groove at this point and have some idea of what's going to happen as a direct result of that.
I was telling somebody the other day that many things are happening to American companies now having to do with race related kind of problems because a lot of the management in American companies and other companies have no frame of reference to these kinds of problems.
And what existed because the people who were there earlier who went through this phase went through all the problems. They went through it. So they have an idea, but most of those people either dead or gone, are they retired and they're no longer seen.
The people who are there running many as a company is in many aspects of the country, many divisions of the companies. They have no idea.
They don't have no idea of what happened way back. Oh, maybe they read a memo, but they have no idea about what's happening. And that's why you have today.
And you were going to have even more so, I'd say over the next two or three years, a lot of race related kind of problems, major companies, because they are not prepared to deal with them.
They think because they have somebody who's head of diversity, something like that in the company, which is fun, that that's going to be okay.
But usually the person who's in charge of diversity, they may be black, all that may be white, or maybe he's spani.
But if they're not steeped in the historical aspects of what is going on and how it was fixed before and what you need to do to fix it now and how it kind of changes have been made and what's happening in the marketplace and all that.
If you're not versed in that, you're going to have a problem. The company is going to have a problem.
Or whatever you're allied with, government agencies are going to have a problem. And so now you have problems cropping up all over place as a direct result of people not understanding the dynamics of what any kind of historical reference to what is going on.
Because many of these problems had gone on, they were going on 30, 40 years ago. I've been in this business over 50 years.
And we were dealing with some of this stuff 40 years ago, 30 years ago.
And now you see it coming around again.
You see it coming making full circle, full circle, same kind of stuff.
And because they have no reference, they don't know how to deal with it. And they have no frame of reference on much of this stuff.
So, let's talk, if you could tell us a little bit about your time in Richmond and then coming back here and police officer, federal agent and starting the company.
And then maybe a little bit. What's that? And the name of the company, yeah, of course.
So we'll start with just after high school, I guess.
Well, after high school, I went to Virginia University, I stayed a year there. And then my grandparents who raised me got ill. I came back home and enrolled at North Carolina A&T State University.
I spent a year there and close to the end of that school year, I went to take a police examination because I thought it was directly related to a class in sociology that I was taking on the Dr. Robinson who was the Dean of the School of Social Work.
And it was, I made an A in the course, I took the police exam and helped me generate some thoughts on what ought to be done.
And about two weeks after I took that exam, which was about the end of the school year, I had a meeting, the captain of police detectives came to my house.
And he saw my grandmother and I had come home from school, school was about out and I hadn't come to my own school that afternoon.
So when I got home from Greensboro, my grandmother said to me, Captain Johnson, sort of police station, been here looking for you. And I asked him, was there anything wrong? And he said, no, no, we just want to talk to him.
So my grandmother was, I mean, she was shaking, she was throwing in, but he was not coming back in, you know, policeman, at least captain of conduct detectives, going to your house, me.
Not a good thing. So she said, well, he said he wanted to call him, so was he getting him.
So I went out and called him and I had to go across the street because we didn't have a telephone. And I went across street and this Dunlapse house and called him.
And he said, Robert, you're home, I said, you're certain. He said, well, we're going to come down and see. He said, we just want to chat with you a few minutes.
I said, you're certain. I'll be here. He said, well, we're going to get in the car and come on down there. So police station wasn't that far away. It's downtown, which was about maybe 10 minutes, 15 minutes away.
So he came down and I decided I stand out to him and to push so that my grandmother, my grandfather in the house, so I went on and so I stood out there and they drove up here in another least detective.
Got out the car, came up on the porch and he introduced himself. He said, I'm Captain Johnson from the police department. And he said, we just want to talk to you for a few minutes.
That's a yes sir. What can I do for you? He said, well, we want to offer you a job as a policeman.
I said, off me job. I said, you're kidding. He said, no sir, we're not kidding. He said, you took the police examination and a couple weeks ago.
And you made the highest mark in about an hour and a half. You know, the police examination. And we wanted to reach out to you and see if you want a job.
I had just turned 21 years old. And I said, well, let me think about it. I'll let you know and they'll tell you. He said, okay, well, he's my card and my phone number's on that you call me.
And so I went back in the house and my grandmother, where she was so nervous, my grandfather said, they said, what are you not in any trouble? I said, no man.
So I said, they wanted to offer me a job as a policeman. And I ran them on the sand. Oh, you can't take a job as a policeman. You're in college. You got to go and finish college.
And both of them were ill and money was almost nonexistent. And I said, mama, I said, I don't know. Let me think about it.
And so school was about out. So I went to school and mixed my money. And I thought about it all of that day. And I came back home that afternoon.
And I went in and talked to my grandmother and grandfather. I told them, I said, I think I'll take this job for a year or two. And then I'll go back to school and maybe I can go to school at night, take some night classes.
And so they were along with me and said, you know, I took the job. I stayed on the job for a couple of years.
Were there many black police officers in high point then?
I think there were maybe four or five. There were two black detectives and I think two or three officers.
And but I took the job.
Have were things in the police department then in terms of race relations.
They were they were fair. They weren't the best, but they were fair.
You know, blacks were supposed to be controlling black areas and all that. And were supposed to rest any white people.
I mean, you know, this was written down there. And of course, you know, I got right in the mix because I hadn't been there for about six months.
And one day, my partner, that was a black guy. We got a call. It was a call on the radio. I mean, radio was out there about all the cars.
All cars is a white male loose down off all those street. And he's he's running. And we all cars converge on that area.
And we can need to get him in tow and so forth. Anyway, I went. We went down there. And I grew up in that area. That was the area grew up inside new all the branches and where you could hide and couldn't have.
So I told my partner he drove around. I told him where to let me off. He let me out. And I told him to drive around and wait at the other end of the branch.
Oh, I said on the place that he can run and not expected to be caught is in that branch because everywhere else everybody does see him. And sure enough, that's what this guy did.
He jumped in that branch. It was running out the brain. And so soon as I got out of the car, my guy drove off. I said, just just like running up through that branch.
I mean, he was trucking up to the brain. So I jumped down in that branch. And I said, hey, stop. I said, you under arrest. And he said,
you know, nigga boy, get out of my way. You better get out of my way. You talk about you can't arrest me. No way. I said, I can't. So I took my black jacket out and I hit him with it. Damn.
You know, I drug him out of there. I said, come on, get up. I drug him out of the branch because you know, I had to figure anything could have done that branch. And they wouldn't be finding me on him till he's way away.
So I hit him a couple of times and drug him out of the branch. You've been not hitting me no more with that black jacket. And I hit him again.
So I said, you better get up and walk. I'm going to do more than hit him. I'm going to take my pistol. So he got up. We got him on part of branch.
And soon as we got up out of branch, they were police cars. I hadn't showed up on the other end. So they came back. All the cars converted. My partner and the white guys would have.
And they took him. They came and they took him and they they beat him up. And they threw him in the car. And so I had to go up there and sign a warrant against him in the police station.
And I thought maybe they were something that might say something. Well, you know, you don't have to do that. No. I went up there and signed a warrant. And everything else. And they kept him in jail and just when they had tried to go down the door, threw the book at him. He stayed in jail for a third or four years.
But up until that time, I don't think there had been any kind of in a facing like that. But nobody said anything. So after that was over, you know, nobody. And this was in in 1956 or like that.
And after that was over, nobody thought anything else about it. Nobody ever said you couldn't arrest a white, you know, never written thing. But it just sort of, you know, under current, you know, arrest white people. But then you saw that change.
I saw that change because I arrested several more white people. I know there was a white guy on the Washington Street in a black area. And I was down there one day just walking the street. And he was down there drunk and raised in particular hell on the street.
And so I saw all of the blacks looking at the Bobby shop doors and everything, you know, and they were wondering what I was going to do because I'm there, you know, I'm just patrolling on foot that day.
And so I'm walking down the street and this guy's kind of losing about half-duced and he's walking out street cursing and raising and saying it.
And then he saw me, he looked up me, saw me, and he called me a nigga, you know, and stuff. So I said, okay. So I crossed the street over where he was and I said, you're on the rest.
And he says, oh, he called me a nigga again. You can't arrest me. You better get out of my way. So I took my black jacket out and hit him one time. It's hard as I could hit him.
And he said, oh, you better hit him. And he fell down on one knee. So I took my cups out and put the cups on him and he strapped him up.
And then I told one of the guys in the Bobby shop somebody that you get on your phone and call station telling me to send the card down here. I got somebody on the rest.
And before I could get him up, Adam Cards for sirens or coming, Cards, whatever they came down here. And they threw him in the car and he told me, he said, you better come on up here and sign a warrant and get this rascal, you know.
And I think they probably beat him up a little bit on the way up to you know. So you know, was that kind of a situation.
So it was an interesting, that was an interesting part of my life. And then I got a job as a federal agent as a result of my being a policeman.
I had helped some federal agents do some work. And so I got a job in New York and my post-duty was New York City. I started working on the mafia.
And ended up, you know, a testifying in the Vito Genovese case, which is the biggest mafia case ever. Several of those guys in that case were defended somehow.
And I worked in Canada, the guy who was the biggest mafia guy there, who worked up there. And I worked in Pennsylvania and in New York all over New York.
I made a lot of cases, similar to biggest cases of it in the Bureau. And then after about three years, I decided I didn't want to do that anymore.
I wanted to go into the public relations business. I read about public relations and there's something I wanted to do. And so I read more books and so forth.
So one day I came home and told my wife, I want to go into the public relations business. And she said, oh, Robert, you don't know anything about public relations.
And she said, oh, you know about what you read in those books. You've been reading. I said, yeah, but I know enough to know that this is what I want to do in my life.
Four or five months later, I resigned my job and we packed up and came back to Naka, and my district supervisor at the time in New York had said, you've been a great agent.
And she said, why you want to mess this up? You say you stay here for 20 years and you can retire and you build a young man.
He said, if you go to Naka, I hope my public relations business. You know, you can't get no class. He said, your people can't even go in restaurant.
I said, oh, you talking about you know, my public relations business in North Carolina. See if you go do that, you'll stand in the York.
I said, no, I'm going back to North Carolina to help deal with the problems here. And I said, I'll be able to work everywhere from there.
He said, okay. So I came back. That's his history.
Now, did you have a sense that of the timing at that time that there was something brewing that I knew that there was something brewing?
And the sit-ins had occurred. And then there were things, and I was still reading. And that's what kept me abreast.
You know, New York tribes and all these papers I had to read. I was living in New York, so you know, communication there was great.
And I saw where all these things were happening, all of the country. And I said, oh, something's, this is not going to go away.
It's going to be a change for everyone. And so I decided that that was where I wanted to be. I wanted to be in the arena.
And so I came back home to do that. I didn't feel like I could do that. So the way I wanted to do it in New York, I was like that.
I needed to be in North Carolina. I needed to be where the action was going to be in the South.
Okay. Okay. And so if you could tell us about just the name of the company and when you started it.
Okay. I started at the end of 1960, December 1960. I came back here and started this business.
And then, you know, I pursued it and I had a 1960 Ram, a car.
And I would go around. I made up a list of the companies. I made up a scenario of what I wanted to do and so forth.
And I wanted to do it. And then I went around to see if I could go in these doors, go in the doors and see these people at these companies.
And I got to see a lot of them. I drive different places. And many times I'd have to sleep in my car.
Well, I was if he was in the South, I'd sleep in my car because I couldn't get a hotel.
And if I was in the North, many times, if I was driving in New York or somewhere else, many times I wouldn't have the money.
I'd have to have the money to save money for my gas. And so I'd sleep in my car, go to the wire and have a shower and shade and change clothes.
And I'd keep a nice, press suit and shirt and tie it. And they wouldn't know whether I came out of the walled off a story, but I came out of back in my car.
So I would do that. And that's the way I pursued it. And I pursued it with some big up and kept doing it.
And the company name?
The name of my company is B and C Associates. When I started out, I had a friend of mine.
He had just come back from the service. He'd been in service. And he stayed with me. His name was Campbell.
And he stayed with me for about three months. And after that time, he says, hey, look, I gotta go find myself a job. My wife says, I have to find a job.
And I said, I don't know what this thing is going to work here. So he left. And I just never changed the name. I said, hey, look, what's in the name anyway.
So I kept the name and kept on moving.
So often, I think when we think of the movement or making change, we think of these big public events and not what's happening behind the scenes or the closed doors or the money or the public relations that it takes.
Could you talk a little bit about what it does take to make change happen, to make a movement?
From a company point of view?
Yeah, from a company point of view.
Yeah, I mean, both, I think. And I'll ask some more questions too, but we'll start there.
You could say from a civil rights point of view. I had access to a number of companies. I had some access to some funding from these companies.
And I did some very innovative things because what I would do is, for instance, when I started working closer with Dr. (Martin Luther) King and Reverend White, T. Walker, who was Dr. (Martin Luther) King's assistant and executive vice president of the SCLC, he was literally running everything on a day-to-day basis.
And they needed all kind of help. They told me up front that he'd help and he did. He'd help with money, and he'd logistic who helped with this and that and the other open doors.
And I used what I had. For instance, many of these companies that I worked with, they would budget so much money for this and he said,
that, tell me, you have access to this and any other. And some of them, I didn't have any budget. I mean, I just did what I needed to do and build them for it.
So what I would do is, if Dr. (Martin Luther) King in the moment needed my help in many ways, and many times that was like finding a meeting and the hotels many times would not go along with him for all kinds of reasons.
They'd have them putting up this and then help. And I'd come in and say, okay, I'll pay this bill. I'll pay that bill.
So many of the movements that took place, I underwrote them. And then I would either suck up that bill myself if I had to flexibility that mind of doing that period.
All I would charge off to one of the major companies, Woolworth or something. And then I would tell them, you know, I have to have this flexibility to do, you know, to work with everybody.
And I would just like to build it. You'll work with me. This is where I work. So I just charge it off as a business development kind of thing. And that was it.
Now, what would a Woolworths, you talked about how really one of your first or your first major client really opened the doors to out of other clients. But what did they want from you?
I mean, how did they put that into what did they want you to do for them? I mean, they saw the winds of change, right? But what did that mean exactly?
Well, they didn't know what it means. And seriously, you know, they didn't even understand because nothing like this had ever happened in America before.
Nothing like this had ever happened in our country before. It was nothing that they could compare it with. They couldn't go to the Harvard Business School and say, look, how do you put this?
What is the equation? I was kind of crazy to use on this one. They couldn't do that. And so, you know, I was planning on new ground. There was nothing to compare it. There were no books written on this because none like this had ever happened in America before.
So, I had to use my own judgment, my own ingenuity and so forth. And my ingenuity told me in what my grandmother raised. She said, just do the right thing.
And my grandmother was living in it. I would talk to her many times, tell her, say, mom, I got to deal with this and this and that. And she would tell me. She said, you tell me over and over again.
She said, mom, those are King Jim is a wonderful man. And those fellows, Bob, they're wonderful people. You need to continue to help them. All you can. She said, just do the right thing. And that's what I was trying to do, the right thing.
And I knew they were on solid ground. I knew that that was a winning cause. They had a lot of detractors, many in the black community. And a lot of men in white community, we did not like them.
And so forth. But they were my friends. And I had to figure out all over again, time and time again, how I could be helpful to them, how I could open doors.
And how I could change the attitudes of major business people in the business community about what was happening and how this would be good for our country.
And I've made speeches to different groups, different heads of companies who would be meeting at the Westchester Country Club or other places around the country, different countries companies on race relations on what do you do in a crisis situation and how you should handle it.
And how to deal with change and all that. I mean, these were all new things in America that had never happened in America before. Never.
I mean, you know, since slavery, slavery was one thing. But then the 60s comes in between the 60s and between the 1960s and the 1860s.
You know, you had reconstruction and you had this and another and part of slavery. But there was nothing, nothing that they could compare themselves with that would prepare them for this, but what was happening at that time. So all this was new ground.
Now, did you have to sell them on the power of the black consumer dollar?
Oh, yeah. That was a constant sale. In many times, that would be the only argument that I would have.
Because I would do research and then I hired some professors at A&T. There was a man, his name was Dr. Sidney Evans, who was an economist at A&T.
He became one of my principal consultants. He was consulting with me for 25 years. And he knew a lot about there were other men like Sidney, who I hired to work with me, who wrote papers and did all kinds of things to say to the business community.
And he was here. He is what the black market is. He is what you dealing with. And here is the power in it, not just from the standpoint of economic power, but power of the black church, power of the black schools.
All kinds of latent power within the black community that was going to come and rise up and you had to deal with this.
And that was what I was selling. I was selling that, hey, look, this is coming. Whether you like it or dislike it makes no difference.
So the good of your company and for the good of America, you have to be in front of this. You have to deal with this. You have to make a way.
Because C companies like Woolworth, they didn't even have a black secretary in the Woolworth headquarters building. But they had stores all over the black community in Chicago, New York. They had Woodward stores everywhere in California and Watson.
They had black assistant managers many times in black areas for very few if you know almost no black managers of the stores in black communities.
So I told me we got a dispense, but this we got to go far in a some black men's. We got to train them. We got to bring them in. We got to put people on the board of directors of the company, black people.
You got to put people in the executive office of the company. You got to have black buyers and all that. We did all of that into the work company.
And because we did it there and they were the biggest, the others kind of took on. They didn't have too much of a choice.
Because many of these guys who were on the board, they were the most pop of business men in America.
So if they you know how to business here, you see one doing it and the others almost going to fall in place.
And they saw what was happening to a lot of them who didn't fall in place. You know they were boycotts, they were demonstrations, they were all kinds of things.
Because we work was hitting very hard. And you know the strange thing about go will work thing is that we started working with them in 1961 probably about July, August, 1960.
Four or five years after we started working with them and they were supposed to be in terms of the black community in terms of companies.
The devil re incarnated. And but about five years later, we'll work out two or three awards for being one of the leading companies in terms of civil rights, in terms of integration and all that.
Because we integrated the executive office, we integrated the board.
But you know, we integrated the you look at war stores around the country, we integrated that.
We even had there was a huge war store in in Holland that was owned by blacks.
We had we changed ownership. They had the store when it was burned out for the rights and stuff.
We had a store turned around and we put it in the limited cooperation where it is stored and built in.
Well owned by black is a sale lease bag deal where we worked a long term lease.
And the land and everything was owned by black people. We did that in some communities all across the country.
And now you know, it seems like we've gone backwards because you doing very little of that. Now, we're black people.
You know, other people are still doing all that sale lease bag deals and stuff. But you don't have a lot of black people involved.
We started this all way back.
So Woolworth's new, or I guess I should put this in the form of a question.
So did Woolworth's know that they had, they really had a problem on their hands just the fact that their name became sort of synonymous with picket, with the pickets.
Oh yeah.
And that they had to turn that around in some way.
I think they understood. They understood.
Well, there were some people who didn't want to deal with it, I think.
But they understood.
What kind of resistance did you meet when you took on these projects for the big corporations?
I met with resistance, all kinds of resistance.
I met with resistance in the black community.
I met resistance in the white community.
For instance, in Birmingham, many of the guys who in Dr. (Martin Luther) King was trying to get the stories down there to integrate and so forth.
Well, I was working through Woolworth and some other companies because Woolworth's biggest.
Woolworth says, yeah, they'll do it.
But the rest of them, they're not only going to integrate their lunche account, they didn't want to integrate their lunche rooms and that kind of stuff.
The big department store, they didn't want to hire no blacks and just that number.
So Woolworth was the big daddy in the National Retail Association at the time.
And that was the big daddy of all of them, all the members of that.
So Woolworth had me to meet with those people and get into the facts of life and everything.
And so when Dr. (Martin Luther) King and Dr. Walker went to them and talked to them about, then Woolworth passed a word down that they were going to integrate.
They were going to, not only integrate, they're going to take the business, they're going to figure out a way how to take the business, all the business and have people coming to their stores and so forth.
And so if dollars has done computing, the gas and all the set, everybody starts coming together.
So they got the message, the dollars went up there somewhere, they got the message and they all agreed that there would be a certain time when all of them would come together, all the stores would integrate.
Same way with the hotels.
I remember when Dr. (Martin Luther) King and those integrated the hotels in Memphis, Tennessee, for instance.
In Memphis, there was a hotel called the The Peabody Hotel. That was the main hotel there.
They still be there. It was an old nice hotel.
It is. When it ducks, walk up, you know that.
So Dr. Walker called me one day. He said, Bob, we got a tentative agreement with the The Peabody Hotel in the downtown hotels that they're going to integrate.
And we're going to have a big meeting there at some point in the next couple months.
But we got a test to hotel to see if they're going to do the right thing first.
And he said, Dr. (Martin Luther) King, once you go there and see if they'll let you in and so forth.
So I said, well, okay, if he really wants to do it. So I flew to Memphis.
And some of the guys met me. Some of the SCLC guys met me and they were seeing what was happening.
So I went there and went to the counter and told them I wanted to sweep.
I wanted to want to kind of be a bit sweeter. So they gave me a bit sweet.
Signed me up. I went up there and took the sweep.
And then I came back and I met with some of the guys.
I said, man, y'all coming up. We're going to have some drinks and dinner up daily.
They don't want to see it in a three. It was a big sweep.
The first time I'm black and ever had a sweep.
But they wanted to test it to see what was going on.
But I mean, I used to do so many different things, all over the place, all over the place.
I know that there were some things going on in Richmond.
And Dr. (Martin Luther) King wanted to make sure that they were worked out okay.
And we got in the middle of that. And what walk was a great tactician.
He was a brilliant guy in the movement.
And I don't think he ever really got the kind of critic that he deserved.
Because he was there in doing those difficult days.
He left later on and went to be an executive in a pubs and come to New York and took a large church there and so forth.
And he still lived in, he has been ill last few years and he lives in Virginia.
But there were just, there was so many things going on.
That we were a part of and participating in it some way.
The Poor People's Campaign.
Dr. (Martin Luther) King was planning on that when he was killed, you know, Poor People's Campaign.
This is 1968.
1968 was an unbelievable perilous year.
Because in 1968, I'm working with Dr. (Martin Luther) King in the movement and so forth with the door of the lot of them.
They were holding meetings with planning for the Poor People's Campaign and all of that.
And then Dr. (Martin Luther) King is killed.
And I go with Mr. King to Memphis to pick up his body.
And then we had Dr. (Martin Luther) King's funeral and the night before the funeral,
I had a big suite at the Hyatt Regency where we met with a lot of people.
People like, I think, Sidney Poitier was there.
Robert Kennedy, Robert F. Kennedy, who had met on cell occasions.
He was there with his wife, Ethel.
And just a whole host of people who came to the funeral, talked about where we were going in the country and all of that.
And then later on, after that, Earl Graves, who worked with me in the Bureau.
And we had been friends for a long time, called me and said, you know,
we wanted to push the Robert Kennedy's campaign on the uptune of level.
And I started working with him on that.
And then a few months later, Bob Kennedy is killed in California.
And it was all this happened in 1968.
And then we still try to plan the Poor People's Campaign.
And then a few weeks later, one of my guys who was working for the Nixon Campaign,
who was working for Ray Bliss, who was the chairman of the Republican National Committee.
Black guy, Clarence Townes, wanted me to work with him, give him advice and counsel on what he ought to be doing and all that kind of stuff.
And I agreed to do that two days a week.
Two days ran into five days, five days in the seven days.
And I was handling a lot of different problems for them.
And then after a few weeks, I was called in by Bob Finch, who was running Nixon's campaign.
He was the took of California Chairman Nixon campaign.
He told me that Richard Nixon wanted me to be on a plane with him,
that he'd been watching what I'd been doing for his campaign.
And he wanted me to travel with him.
So I came back home, got myself together, and went back to the campaign in Ohio,
and we went across the state on the last whistle stop train tool that any president has taken in America.
Nixon took it across Ohio.
And that's where we saw the sand with little girl holding up his head, bring us together.
And that became a campaign theme for us.
And I worked in travel with Nixon until the end of the campaign.
And what did you think of Nixon when you first met him or got involved in the campaign?
I thought he was smart.
And many times intuitive and sensitive to a great degree.
I didn't consider him a lot of people wanted to tag him as a racist.
I think he wasn't a racist.
He was everything but a racist.
And then I got to even know him better after the campaign was over.
And after campaign was over, I told him that they wanted me to go to help put your government together,
and put it down to keep us king.
I told him I was going back to North Carolina, put my business back to get there.
I'll take a little pause.
You've been working through your company for Nixon, right?
So you were getting paid for that?
That wasn't volunteer work.
It wasn't regular paid that I think they paid me something at what much.
Now when you worked with the movement, was that all just on your own time?
I was raising money and giving him money.
I was giving it to everybody.
But there was something that I wanted to do.
I needed to do it.
I was making the contacts.
I had the contacts.
And I thought one dog teal into another.
And then I got to see you.
Now did King first reach out to you or how did you make that connection with King and some of the other movement leaders?
I was having lunch in Atlanta with a friend of mine, Stanley S. "Stan" Scott, who read in Atlanta Daily World, like an inspiration.
And he introduced me to Rebel Rev. Wyatt Tee Walker, who was Dr. (Martin Luther) King's right hand man.
And Rebel Walker says to me, he said, you know, he said, you're in a putter relationship and he said, we need your help.
He said, why don't you come back to office when you finish your lunch?
And me with Dr. (Martin Luther) King, he said, Dr. (Martin Luther) King's in town, he would love to meet you.
And I said, you know, no problem.
I said, I like what he's doing.
That's how it happened.
I went by the office of me, Dr. (Martin Luther) King.
Dr. (Martin Luther) King says, hey, look, we need your help.
You know, we need, we try to raise money.
We need the best man we can get.
We just try to make it through him.
That's how we met.
Interesting.
So jumping back to President Nixon, then you were talking about it.
Once that government started to, they started to form that government
and asked you to be a part of that.
Oh, yeah.
And so I initially, you know, I said, no, I can't do that.
I got to go back and make some money.
And so every day I would get a call from Ron, so he'd go to somebody.
But then Nixon office, asking me about this, and what they ought to do about this, then you know.
So one day I got a call from (H.R. "Bob") Haldeman.
This was about a third or four week in November, 68.
And (H.R. "Bob") Haldeman said, Bob, I'm calling you because your man wants to see you.
And he wants to see you right away.
I said, well, I got to come to New York anyway.
Even New York, it was at the Pierre Hotel.
That's where the transition office was.
I said, I'll come back tomorrow.
And I'll come around and come back.
And so I flew to New York.
And went to the Pierre (Hotel) + (H.R.) Haldeman, met me, and he said,
I'll take you with me.
So he took me up to Nixon's suite.
Herbert Brownell Jr and William P. Rogers, when Brownale had been turned to Joe under Eisenhower,
and Rogers was going to be Secretary of State.
He had Nixon had named McCabney, and didn't even have a real staff.
And so when I walked in, the room, and (H.R. "Bob") Haldeman said, Nixon, he said,
oh, I didn't know you had people in here.
He said, I got Bob Brown with me, and we would just wait outside until you finished.
He said, oh, no, no, no, no.
He said, these guys are leaving.
I got to talk to Bob.
He said, bring Bob on in.
I don't want to introduce him to these guys.
So I came in, and he introduced me.
He said, this is Bob Brown.
I want to cheer all of you in here, because you all want to be seeing a lot of him.
He said, he's going to be one of my principal assistants in the White House.
Now we had him have to come and say say, any amount of conversation.
And that's why he introduced me to Brownell and William P. Rogers.
And so they left.
And then (H.R. "Bob") Haldeman says, do you want me to stay at Sticker Brown here?
And he said, oh, no, I want to meet with Bob.
So the two of us met for a long time, maybe 45 minutes or more.
And a lot of the time he's telling me about different things, about the blacks that he knew.
And he started telling me about this story about E. Frederic Morrow, who was in the White House when he was vice president.
And he said, Bob, I know you probably heard.
You might know E. Frederic Morrow.
He said Fred Mar was a top grade guy. He was brilliant smart.
He said, but they had him sitting as the black sitting beside the door.
He said, they didn't give him any real responsibility.
He said, that was wrong. He was a brilliant man.
He said, he was probably smarter than any of the guys that I had around him.
And he said, just didn't give him a break.
He said, but you don't have to worry about that.
You have total access to me.
And he said, in Washington, access is everything.
It's everything.
And he said, you got my confidence and my access.
He said, that's all you need.
He said, no, no, no, don't want your title.
If you got access, you got it all.
And I found out he was right. And he never changed that.
The whole time, I was at the White House for four years and three months.
And to the whole time, I was at the White House.
There was never a 10.
Never a 10 when anybody overruled me.
I mean, there were times when people tried about anything that I did there.
Including the President.
And there were some very sticky situations.
There was one of them where one of the big associations who had given President a lot of money in his campaign.
They wanted to change some of the stuff that I was doing because I was doing the whole Black Economic Development thing and all this.
I was getting Blacks involved with contracts and grants and stuff that they had never been involved with before.
And that was stuff that they had control over to all these contracts.
And they thought I was trading on their ground.
And they told Haldeman they wanted to see the President talk to him about firing me.
Because Haldeman came and told me, he says, you know, these guys, he said, you're going to trade lightly or whatever.
And I said, I'm just doing work. I think the President wants me to do.
So Haldeman says, I got to go tell the President what they want.
I said, we'll tell it. No problem.
So he went to the President, what they wanted.
And Haldeman called me back. He said, Bob, he said, the President wants you to see them.
He said, but the President said, he's not going to see him back to come and see you.
And these guys would give him a lot of money.
And they came and see me.
And I told him, I said, hey, look, we want to work this out.
But it's not going to be the same thing as it's always been.
I said, we want to prove some of nobody is some women in this deal.
These deals in that.
I said, you all had it all.
But we can't do that.
This is a different kind of America where we will be running here right now.
And the President backed me up.
And those guys became friends.
I mean, you know, because I was going to take more than I took.
Now, did the President give you a brief as to what he exactly he wanted to see?
Oh, yeah.
He talked about, he told me in that meeting, at a initial meeting, in the P.R. Hotel.
He said, look, I've talked about in the campaign, he talked about black capitalism.
He said, you know, I made a speech about black spinning business and doing this and that and the other.
He said, but I don't really, he said, you know more about this kind of thing than I do.
He said, you work with art, my little king, you work with civil rights, you travel all over the country with different black groups.
With the church groups and the school.
He said, you need to, you need to handle this.
He said, I'm looking to you to deal with it.
And he said something else that was very important to me.
He said, whenever we have a cabinet meeting, he said, you will be at all the cabinet meetings.
He said, you'll make every time a cabinet meets you will meet.
He said, he'll probably be five or six senior staff in the cabinet meetings.
Every cabinet meeting was held if I was in town, even if I was out of town and could be back there by the time of the meeting.
I mean, out of cheer with my name.
It was your title was special.
No, no, I have a cheer.
But then you could do some other things.
I brought my cheer home, my cheer is in the office down the road of my name.
Let's take a break.
Okay, start again.
How does your end up going south after here in the first place?
Well,
I went to South Africa, I had gone there on a couple of occasions with Ambassador Doug Holliday.
It was especially Ambassador South African.
I also went there to take about 20 black college presidents of South Africa who wanted to go.
And the South African government gave us visas to get ordained because it was hard to get a visa.
So then there's a king called me one day.
She said, Bob, she was a very close friend.
So she said, Bob, I want to go to South Africa.
And you know all those people over there.
And because we can't get a visa.
She said, my people try to get a visa.
So I'll call Piet Koornhof, who was the ambassador to South Africa to the United States.
And I had met Piet at a prep repress in Washington.
And he considered himself as strong about Christian and so forth.
So I told him I wanted to see him.
He said, okay, you come and have lunch with me, Bob.
I said, okay.
So I went to the embassy at lunch with him.
I said, you know, Coretta Scott King, my little King's widow, said she wants to go to South Africa.
And she wants to take to my staff with her.
But she can't get a visa to get into the country.
And I said, this is not the Christian way.
You know, you need to do something else with this.
I said, I don't know what this is, Piet.
You know, you spoke to me, my Christian brother.
But the country is known as this kind of thing.
He said, Bob, no, no, that's not right.
You know, Coretta Scott King wants to go.
I said, you know, I don't know that her.
We have a visa.
He said, you get me all the information.
And we'll get it worked out.
We'll get it again.
I said, okay.
So I'll call Coretta Scott King.
Coretta Scott King has one of the staff to get all the information.
All the people will go.
Got the information.
And within a few days, we had the visa spread by the one to come.
And the other problem was, there were a number of people
who Miss King wanted to go.
They didn't have no money.
I mean, you know, we were doing it under the banner of the King Center,
which she had established.
They didn't have any money.
So I had gotten raised in money for the make the trip.
And so anyway, we went over there.
And one other thing that she said she wanted to do
was to go see (P.W.) Botha to see if we could get him
to let Nelson Mandela out of jail.
She said, I really think I can do this part.
I said, okay, no problem.
This is what year is this?
Approximately?
This was about 19...
1986 maybe.
Okay.
So we went to South Africa.
And when we got there,
we met with a group of people in South Africa,
like Dr. Allan Boesak and others.
And they all were urging us not to meet.
The music king shouldn't meet with (P.W.) Botha.
And he said, okay.
And Miss King, some of the people that she had taken with her,
and I said they were rethinking the meeting with (P.W.) Botha.
And so, after we got there, we stayed up all night discussing
with some of the leadership in South Africa
and some of the people who lead U.S., in the US saying
that most of them came to conclusion that we shouldn't meet
with (P.W.) Botha.
And that's one of the reasons Miss King was over there.
She's over there for a couple of reasons.
One of the other reasons was
to be made an archbishop at the time.
And she was going to attend his ceremony.
And nobody, when it came to meet with (P.W.) Botha,
she wanted to meet with (P.W.) Botha to ask for him
a medal out of jail and a medal out of jail.
And see, this is something that never really is surfaced.
But most of the people in that meeting,
they didn't want Miss King to meet with (P.W.) Botha.
So we thrashed that out over all night long.
I mean, literally all night.
And we're still at talk about this.
So Miss King decided to say, Bob,
I don't want to go against the wishes of the people
here on the ground and dealing with this.
She said, I'm not going to do this.
She said, I'm going to write a letter to (P.W.) Botha
and tell him that I can't meet with him and so forth.
So she wrote the letter.
And of course, who gets picked to take the letter
to the State House.
So I told him I would do it after he picked me.
So I went over there to tell him that she wasn't going to be
meeting with him because he had agreed to meet with her.
And he wouldn't meet with anybody, but he had agreed to meet with her.
And she was going to ask me, the man tell us release,
but she didn't want to.
So anyway, I took the letter and I went through the gate.
I let me through the gate and went to (P.W.) Botha's office.
And this guy met me when his assistance met me.
And I delivered the letter and I said, please give us a letter
from Miss King to (P.W.) Botha.
And I said, she deeply regrets this.
She could not meet with him at this time.
And he looked at me and he said, Mr. Brown,
he said, we certainly appreciate Miss King Bing here.
And we appreciate you delivering this letter to (P.W.) Botha
telling him what Miss King's wishes were.
And he said, we respect her wishes.
And I said, thank you very much.
And we were called to maybe greeting you again sometimes.
So I turned around left.
So I went back and Miss King says, Bob,
she said, one of the things that I need to do before I leave this country,
I need to go see Winnie Mandela.
Now we went Cape Town.
Johannesburg is two and a half hours away by plane.
And so we got in touch with Miss Mandela, Miss Mandela.
So you had to love to see Miss King.
So we flowed to Johannesburg.
Went to Soweto.
It spends some time with Miss Mandela.
So we're sitting there talking, talking, talking about everything.
And so Miss King asked, Miss Mandela, what would you,
what would be most important to you and Miss Mandela for us
that we could do for you all now?
And Miss Mandela was loud and clear.
She said, the thing that Nelson and I want most is for our children
to be able to go back to America and go to school.
She said that there are a number of people over here who promise that.
But nobody has ever delivered.
So you know, people promise in America, and you never hear from them anymore.
That's what Miss Mandela told Miss King.
So Miss King looked at me and she says, Bob, is this something that we can do?
I knew what she meant.
So I told her.
I told her, I told Miss Mandela, I said, I told Miss King, I said, yes, I think we can do it.
And I said, but what we need, what I need is I need a letter from Miss Mandela
to me personally asking me to do this.
And then I'll set it in the motion.
And sure enough, about two or three weeks later, I get a letter from Miss Mandela asking me to do this.
And so I set it in the motion.
I called President Boston University, who's a close friend, and I was on that board.
I'm still on that board of trustees in the university.
And he agreed to do, he agreed to take care of the tuition and so forth.
But I would have to take care of all the other expenses, getting them over here, house, a van
because they had Mandela's three grandchildren at time.
It was four because he had another child and thinks he got it.
And they lived here seven years.
Seven years.
And I paid for it personally.
Not some grant I got from the foundation of from a company, from RGB personally.
And it was a very expensive proposition.
But it was one that I did because I thought we owed it to them.
And I had told Miss King, who was one of my closest friends that I would do it.
And I did it.
Now, that young woman who came over here is now the South African ambassador to Argentina,
Uruguay, and Paraguay.
She's the only person, only Mandela, a child, a grandchild, who is in an official position with the government.
And that's the money.
Incredible.
So, you never know how things are going to turn out when you pursue different kinds of activity.
But South Africa was a real challenge.
And you met him as soon as he got out of prison?
I met him inside the jail.
I have some material that I'll share with you.
But I met him inside the jail.
They allowed Mrs. Mandela to look when I agreed to take him over and bring him back with me.
I went over there and Mrs. Mandela said, before you lead this country again, you have to see Nelson Mandela.
I said, well, nobody has seen him in 27 years.
How do you think they're going to let me see him?
I said, didn't want me to let you all see him, but 15 minutes of the 10,
and you all traveled 2.5 hours down in Cape Verri from Javasper.
She said, well, I'm going to try.
I'm going to petition President Botha for you to see him, because you're taking you to God in him, his children.
And I thought it was hopeless, useless, hopeless kind of thing for her to do, because I knew they wouldn't want to do that.
The night before I was to leave, I got a call from Niel van Heerden, who was one of the top assistants to President Botha.
And he called me on telephone at the hotel. He said, Mr. Brown, because he said what his name was.
He said, I'm calling for President Botha.
He asked me to call you to tell you that you have permission.
He's granting you permission to see Mr. Mandela tomorrow at Pollsmoor Prison, if you still want to do it.
I couldn't believe it.
Nobody had seen Nelson Mandela in 20-something years.
These people grant me permission to go to Pollsmoor Prison to see him inside the prison.
I mean, it was just so.
I figured maybe they want to kill me, because you know there are a lot of killings and bombings and everything going on with me.
And so I said, oh my goodness.
So I prayed over it.
I asked God to give me strength in the guidance and give me the courage to go ahead and do this.
So I went down to him.
I carried Zenani Mandela and Prince Moosey, a husband with me.
And so we got to the gate and you know they had all these guns and things there.
And that's so, oh my God, it's maybe it's maybe it.
So the guy brought out his big old pad and he says, oh you must have brought him.
He said, yeah.
He said, well, we were going to open the gate and you go to that red brick building up there.
And somebody will come and meet you at the door as soon as you get there.
So we walked through the gate, walked up there to this brick building.
And as soon as I got to the bottom of the steps of the big building, only about three or four steps there,
this big white guy comes out and he grabs my hand.
And he said, Mr. Brown, he said, I'm the cheap warden here.
And what you're doing for Mr. Mandela is a marvelous thing for his family.
And we all want to congratulate you and for what you're doing for Mr. Mandela and his family.
He said, I'm having him brought down from his cell now.
And you go into that big room over there in the corner.
And you sit in there and you talk to him as long as you want to.
Now in 20 some years, nobody is family who they want people to go out and see.
They were on this, let him be seen for 15 or 20 minutes.
And then sometimes they give him an extra 15 minutes.
And they were traveling two and a half hours by plane.
And I've sat there and talked to him about two hours.
He was absolutely mind-boggling.
He told me what it would take to make peace inside the bathroom.
He talked about a lot of things.
I have a memo that I wrote as soon as I got out of the house,
scratching their notes and having a memo that I wrote.
As soon as I got out of the gate and I'll give you a copy of it.
A memo that I wrote about how to meet him.
And then they let me go back the next year.
They let me go back to see him again.
But by this time they were talking to him.
They had never really had any relationship or talked to him.
It wouldn't matter if I didn't talk.
But after I saw him and I wrote this memo and I passed it on to Mrs. Mandela.
She gave it to the ANC.
I passed it on to George Shultz, who was Secretary of State.
I passed it on to President Reagan.
I gave a peak corn off and wrote a copy of it.
So they could send it to President Reagan.
And so forth.
So everybody had it outside, and their side had it.
A&C had everybody had the memo about what Mrs. Mandela was talking about.
And so after that they had started the little conversations with him.
And things started to roll.
What they let it to another and another.
So you just never know what God has in store for you.
And how he's using you.
It's my grandmother used to say, just let God have His way.
Let Him use you.
And things will turn out okay.
But it was an unbelievable time down there in South Africa.
It was amazing.
And then there were other things that happened during that period.
I went into most of the black townships, all of the country.
And I would go to the schools because I figured that was the schools.
And see if they were in the library.
Well, there were very few of almost no libraries because they wouldn't let them have books.
So what I did, it's I decided to start taking books, sending books back to South Africa.
And so as a result, I would take truck rolls of the mega commission from the South African government
that I could bring shoes and clothes.
I didn't tell them I'd bring books.
So in every box of shoes and clothes, I'd have a half a box of shoes and clothes and a half a box of books.
All kinds of school books.
And so I started doing that on a scale.
And I would be going there.
I'd make my point to go there, get the books in there.
And then I get a truck from here, a truck loaded up.
And I'd got permission from the South African government to put those books on South African highways.
And they didn't charge me anything for putting them on there.
So I put those books in the clothes because I told them they were shoes and clothes.
And they look in the box, that's what they would see.
Shoes and clothes, but the other half of the box were number of books.
So I did that for several years.
I took books into...
And you still do that, right?
And still do that.
We set up over 300 live areas in South Africa, over 300.
We set them up in the Zulus in (likely) Zululand, with the King of the Zulus,
who is also a good friend.
And before you leave, I'll show you some pictures.
And we set all of South Africa.
Because books are still precious in Africa, not just in South Africa.
And Africa books are like gold.
A kid gets a book and they start to cry.
And we are threading books over here.
We are threading books about millions, you know, recycling them in their country.
When these people, millions, tens of millions of kids don't have any books.
And they think a book, like a piece of gold.
And they try to make it a book.
So we're going to have to figure that out.
How's your book?
It's in the low end.
You ready to start again?
So maybe let's start there, if you would.
Talk a little bit about President Nixon and his character,
and how he felt about working on race relations.
So to really hear about the work that you are able to do
in stimulating the growth of minority businesses.
Well, first of all, I think a lot of people
have put together in their own minds that President Nixon was devout races.
He was a devout quaker.
And I don't know any racist quakers.
I know that sometimes President Nixon used some language
that he probably regretted or shouldn't have used.
But many people do that.
But many people didn't have a camera on them when they were doing it.
Many Presidents have done that.
And many top people have been around a few when they've used
some bad language.
So he's not the only one who's done that.
But he's the only one who had that camera on him who could
you could show.
And so he was condemned for it.
But he was not a racist.
He was a person.
If he believed in you or if he believed in a cause,
he was totally for it.
And the whole thing of minority business enterprise.
He wanted to have blacks and Hispanics and others
to get a shot.
Because he felt very strongly that if you don't get a shot
within the business community or in business in general,
this whole country is built on that.
And if you were not involved in that,
it was going to be very limited in terms of what you were going
to be able to do in America.
And so he wanted that open up.
And my charge was to do that.
I went to Wall Street.
I went to the biggest banks in the country.
The city group was the biggest bank of the time.
Met with their chairman and CEO and vice chairman
about the whole minority enterprise program
of what we expected in them and their bank to do.
They agreed to work with us.
We organized a national commission on minority enterprise.
And we put the most powerful people in America.
And in it, we designated this chairman of that group,
Mr. Roche, who was James M. Roche,
who was the chairman and CEO of GM,
which at the time was the largest corporation in America
and deed in the world at that time.
He agreed to chair it, not only did he agree to chair it,
but he got other industrial people,
other automobile manufacturers to come on in and give dealerships
to blacks all over the country.
When we went to the White House in late 1968,
in the head, there were only, I think there were only two.
No more than three blacks in America who had
who owned dealerships.
And there were very few who were working in many of these major
manufacturers, you know, like Chrysler, GM, Ford.
Very few were working, almost none.
They were working in the executive positions in these companies.
And they were the top of the day.
Now, I mean, it wasn't people seem to think
that, you know, because you have some blacks there now
and some top positions and all that on boards and so forth,
that all this just happened by osmosis.
It did not happen by osmosis.
It happened because we worked at it and made it happen.
You know, I met James M. Roche became a close personal friend of that.
And when we left the White House, he wanted to expand
what they were doing in terms of a Nord enterprise.
And James M. Roche hired my company for several years to go out
and spirit the word and to get them involved in a whole range
of different kinds of activities with a Nord is across the country.
So, you know, it just didn't happen.
You know, just because I was there and I was sitting up there
as a black person, it doesn't.
It makes some difference whether you are a black person sitting
where I was sitting as a staff person or if you are a black person sitting
as a president in the United States.
If you want some stuff to happen, you got to work at it.
You know, you just can't wish it to happen.
You got to make it happen.
And that's what we were doing.
That's what we did.
And that's what the Nixon years were all about.
And that's what the President Nixon in 1972,
when he ran for reelection, he got 20% of more of the black vote.
And he was supposed to be, according to some history books
and some people, he was supposed to be the devil reincarnated to blacks.
No Republican candidate since 1972 has gotten as many black votes
as Richard Nixon got in 1972.
No candidate.
How did that happen?
When he was supposed to be the devil reincarnated.
We had Jim Brown, we had Sammy Davis Jr.,
we had the president of the Baptist conventions
and some Baptist convention, we had some of the top ministers
in the country and bishops of different churches and so forth.
Who came out in support of President Nixon in 1972.
That's how it happened.
Because they knew we were working closer with them.
They knew that we had a major effort to get major money into black colleges.
We got the first major money into black colleges,
in ever in America.
Richard Nixon did that.
We, as no president before,
since has met with all of the top black that he had in his top positions in administration.
We would meet with all of them at least once a year,
sometimes twice during the course of the year.
And people who were in that group with people like James Farmer Jr,
who was assistant secretary of HEW,
who was the head of CORE.
At that time, it was considered the most radical organization there was on the scene.
He was conducted massive demonstrations and everything else.
But we brought him into the administration as an assistant secretary of HEW
in a top job where he could make things happen.
Where he did make things happen.
We had other people there,
here to the Wormers Bureau and the Labor Department.
We had Arthur A. Fletcher there, who was assistant secretary of labor,
who came up with the Philadelphia plan.
And all those things derived to ship, which we caught to employment.
All those things started under Richard Nixon.
All those things.
And we had people in those jobs,
and who came in mass, we had them in mass, in a way out.
I have pictures here to show you what we were doing and who we were meeting with.
And these pictures would go out to the Washington Post,
New York Times and all that about these meetings and all this stuff that was going on.
And I don't think not one is our call.
Not one major newspaper printed any of these pictures.
Not one major newspaper.
Now, there's something wrong with that.
Not one major newspaper printed in these pictures of all of this that happened all over the place.
So there were so many different things going on.
Job situations, EEOC.
The first major funding and revamping of EEOC to take it to another level so it could be more effective.
Was done under Richard Nixon.
And William H. Brown III, who's a big lawyer, who made a lot of strats in America, was chairman of it.
For four years.
He's filled it out for you, lawyer.
Talked one of the top lawyers in the country.
Black lawyer.
And there were other things like that that happened over and over again,
where we brought top people, civil rights leaders and other wrong Wilkins, Whitney M. Young Jr.
The president met with Whitney M. Young Jr many times.
The president met with Roy Wilkins, who was head in double-ACP many times.
We did all kinds of things as a result of their suggestions.
What about the federal government patronizing black businesses?
Was that a priority that they started?
That was a big problem.
And that was something that I pursued at a white house level in that Secretary Maurice H. Stans who was Secretary of Commerce.
He and I worked very closely together with that.
He had the responsibility because we set up the office of the minority of business enterprise within the Commerce Department.
And we pursued that with all of the departments of the government.
And not only did we pursue it in terms of contracts and grants,
but along with all the other things that I was doing, I made sure that the Defense Department,
that the other departments that had a lot of money, like General Services Administration, all that,
I made sure that they were giving out contracts and grants and whatever they had to black contractors,
to the black colleges and universities, just as they were doing to other people that they hadn't been doing before we got there.
The figure that I have is that the federal government purchases from black businesses rose from $13 million to $142 million during Nixon's tenure.
During your tenure?
Oh yeah.
I know.
Because we monitored it.
It's another thing we monitored.
In the Korean War, not the Korean War, but Vietnam War was going on at the time.
We were having big trouble, the race-relation problem, and a big race-relation problem.
When we got to the White House, that was one of the big problems.
And blacks were not being promoted.
They were at a certain level.
So when we got to White House in 1969, when Nixon was inaugurated, we had, I think, two or more than three blacks who were Abel, General, and most of the departments,
all that was in the army, I believe.
I think we had one Navy guy, (uncertain - Navy admiral) Samuel L. Gravely Jr, I think he was a real Abel.
But that was it.
When we got there in 1969, one of the things that happened, you know, and I started concentrating on this.
And Daniel "Chappie" James Jr, who we brought over to be the Deputy Assistant Secretary of Defense for Public Affairs, and gave him a star, because he was a Colonel.
He was an ace pilot in two wars, one of the top guys in military that we've ever had.
And he was a Colonel, and it was ace pilot in two wars.
And we brought him over, gave him a star, and put him into the first part.
But when Chappy came to me one day and he said, Bob, he said, we're never going to have a representative number of blacks, unless we get something going on here in this defense department.
It's never going to happen.
So I said, we're going to do something about it, Chappie."
So I talked to a hallemar about it.
And he said, let me go talk to President, and let me tell him, and he said, I'm going to wait until President ever talking to him, see what he said.
And I'll call you back.
About two or three hours later, I could just call from Hallemann.
Hallemann said, Bob, I talked to President, and President thinks he were exactly right, and he wants to be helpful.
He said, he figured out the way that he could be helpful is that every month they send over the list of flag offices, because there's a command and chief, he has to sign off on it.
And so in order to do something about that, Bob, he said, what I'm going to do in the President agreed, what I'm going to do is send you the list.
And when it comes over, you check it out and see if any minorities on the list, he said, if there are no minorities, he said, you let me know, and we'll send it right on back.
We send it back about three or four times in a row.
And so all of a sudden, it must have done on somebody, depending on that, we better do something else.
So they start putting some blacks on there, put a woman on there, and so I would check it out.
And so we started when they started doing that, by the time I left the White House in 1973, we had a whole lot of black generals.
Okay, a whole lot of them, and then they come all over the place after that.
By the time I left there, a chapter of James, who had never had a star when we got there, we gave him his first star.
By the time I left, he had three stars.
And he was the head of our military base in Dingo, that strategic base that we have out there.
But there were just so many things like that that happened over and over.
I mean, it was vastly important. It changed the way we did business in America, with the military, with business people, with all facets of what we were trying to do.
But we had to weigh it in on it. I even set up a special commission.
I did this myself, because I had the President, it's okay to do whatever.
I set up a special commission to go around the world, because we were having race-relations problems, on military bases, all over the world.
I set up a special commission to go around the world, to check this out, and meet with the service people in all these bases.
You find all kinds of problems.
And then I would go from time to time, I would go myself, unannounced, until I got right there near the base.
And I'd have somebody at one of the military guys on the plane with me to call the base and tell him that I'm going to be landing this plane.
He's going to be landing this plane in the next 30 minutes, and that I'm going to meet with the command in office.
Because we'd have intelligence that would be telling us what was happening on different places.
I went to Hawaii. There were a lot of tear in the white, because we had a lot of military bases there.
And the person who was the head of CINCPAC, all of the armed forces in the Far East and from the White White back, was none other than Admiral John S. McCain Jr.
John McCain's father.
I have a picture with him right here somewhere, but he and I are meeting over there in Hawaii.
We became good friends as a result of that.
So it was quite a time.
Amazing work that you did there.
So I have just...
Okay.
Yeah, so just conclude if you could tell us about Sealtest in AMP.
Well, I got this call one day from one of the guys who was traveling to Dr. (Martin Luther) King.
And Dr. (Martin Luther) King was in Cleveland.
And he said that Dr. (Martin Luther) King would talk to me, and he wanted me with me.
And I had a man coming out here and I said, oh no, I can't snake the plane out there.
So when I airport, John don't play with Cleveland.
And when I got there, Dr. (Martin Luther) King came in room, he said, Bob, he said, we got a problem here.
And he said, we got a problem with Sealtest.
He said, you know, we've been trying to meet with them and get them to hire black truck drivers and do some other kinds of things that they need to be doing.
And he said, they won't even meet with me.
They refused to meet with me or any of my people.
And he said, I'm wondering if you have any suggestions of what we can do.
And I told him, I said, yeah, I said, what I need to do.
I said, I have this relationship with the people at A&P, with the top people at AMP,
and the time it's a larger supermarket chain in America.
And I said, you know, I will go to them, I'll call them up, see if I can see them.
And I'll fly there immediately and see what I can do about it.
And he said, well, we need to do something because we want to make some progress, but we're going to have to,
we don't want to tear up everything and make any progress.
So I flew to New York and got a meeting with the CEO of A&P.
And when I went in the room, we expressed the greetings and so forth.
And I told them, let me get right to the point.
He was the point.
I said, Dr. (Martin Luther) King and his people are in the Cleveland Ohio area.
And they're going to have a lot of problems with Sealtest dairy.
I said, the Sealtest management won't meet with Dr. (Martin Luther) King or any of his people.
And I said, there's going to be big trouble there.
And I said, we do not need the A&P stores because AMP was a cloud of that.
So I said, we don't need the A&P stores involved in this.
We're trying to make room in all of the states where A&P is located to have a new relationship.
And I said, we need to be in front of this.
And he said, well, Bob, what would you recommend?
I said, I would recommend that you have somebody to get in touch with A&P,
one of our top executives.
And let them know with Sealtest and let them know that we have a problem with this.
And we don't want to be involved some kind of way.
And he said, you're right, Bob.
Then he called in one of his top assistants.
He came in the room and he said, look, Bob's been telling me about his problem with Sealtest.
And he said, yes, sir.
We know all about it.
It's a problem not to end the Midwest.
And he said, well, I want you to call the top people with Sealtest and tell them
that if they don't get this situation right with Dr. (Martin Luther) King,
that we are going to take Sealtest products out of all of the stores in Ohio.
Now, I had recommended initially that maybe we ought to look at taking the products out of all the stores in Cleveland.
He told him to tell me the products out of all the stores in Ohio.
Before I could hardly get out of the building because I had some more meetings there.
Before I could get out of the building, I called my office and my office told me that
Dr. (Martin Luther) King, people are desperately trying to reach you.
They still include, they need you to talk to you.
So I called out to King.
Dr. (Martin Luther) King said, Bob, he said, I don't know what you told them people.
He said, but the top people at Sealtest have called me several times already.
They want to meet this afternoon.
They want to meet in the morning.
And every time we can meet, they want to meet there at the meet and work with us anyway they can.
So they went and met with him.
And that night, Dr. (Martin Luther) King called a mass rally in Cleveland, a big church there.
At Reverend Hoover's church, Odie M. Hoover.
And so Dr. (Martin Luther) King made this speech.
And in his speech, he talked about Sealtest.
And he talked about me.
He said, you know, we've made a major breakthrough here.
Like we haven't made in a while.
He said, but what Sealtest didn't realize it.
We had Bob Brown on our side.
And he's on our board directors.
And he was a man who made this stuff happen and so forth.
And it's recorded.
There's a recording about this.
You know, I have one somewhere in the office or somewhere.
There's a recording on his speech and what he was talking about.
He said, this is what we're going to do now.
There's a way of the future.
And he talked about my role in everything else and what I'd done for SEAL.
So it was an amazing time.
It's an amazing time.
I mean, as I said, when we started, there's a couple of hours ago that it's not just the, you know, the marches.
But it's these kinds of pressures and arm twisting in the back.
This is how this changes.
If you're not doing that, if you're not making something happen, because it's all about jobs and different kinds of opportunities.
Contracts with minority business people, all of this.
This is what makes the whole thing go around.
This is what makes it all a success.
You know, because the businesses and the jobs are going on all the time.
It's just that you need participation by all the people.
Blacks, Browns, Graves, whatever they are.
You need all the people to participate.
And during the 50s and the 60s for the most part, and sometimes in the 70s, you had only the whites who were participating in all this.
They had SEAL tests and the rest of the milk companies didn't even have any black.
They were taken milk throughout all these communities.
They had thousands of trucks and truck drivers delivered milk.
You remember the milk truck driver?
They didn't have any blacks.
Not a single driver.
They're living black people milk every which way.
Thousands of black people.
Ten thousand.
Didn't have one single driver.
Black.
We changed that.
You know, there are just so many different things like that that happened doing that to it.
I mean, a lot of people look at stuff now and they think it just happened.
You know, like out of the clear booth guy, somebody just got religion one day and said,
we're going to help black people.
You know, no, I didn't have like that.
You had to do some pressure put on them.
And that's what has to happen now.
I mean, you know, this thing with Mr. Obama taking the money away from the black causes
and there are tens of thousands of students who can't go back to school right now, black kids,
because they tighten up the money, the credit qurets, on the parents who could not get the loans anymore,
because the administration did that, you know.
And so many of the black colleges you watch over the next year or two,
many of the black colleges are going to be closing now.
You can't stay up and they don't have students.
So you tell me when.
Okay, so I'll just ask you, if you have any concluding remarks you'd like to make.
I mean, anything that I didn't ask you that I should have asked or you were expecting me to ask that I didn't or anything else you'd like to ask.
No, I think you've done a great job.
I appreciate you coming and appreciate what you all are doing.
Not just for your departments and history departments, all that, but for what to me, Zim is doing.
And what it will represent to ages yet unborn to those kids and to many of the young people today,
they have absolutely no idea what we're going on.
And they'll get this from this museum and what you all are doing now.
And it'll be a guidepost for many people, white, black, whoever,
to see what has happened and to give them some sense of what they ought to be doing in the years ahead.
So I appreciate what you've done and what you continue to do.
Well, thank you so much.
And yeah, it's been a battle just to get the museum as you know.
But I never thought that we would have a black history museum right there in the heart of Washington
in the probably the most proud spot that you can put a museum in the capital of the world.
I think it's fantastic.
Every time I go by the, I just tear just well up in my eyes now, you know, and I'm back at fourth and watched an all day.
But I just, I think it's a wonderful, magnificent thing.
And I congratulate you, all of you, for what you've done, and especially Lonnie and the board and everybody involved.
I think we've done a great job.
And I'm looking forward to seeing the finished product and to getting a lot of young people, blacks and whites and others there.
And particularly all of the young people from Africa, I think they need to see this.
That would help them a great deal.
And I'm in touch with a lot of them.
We're still sending a lot of books in the schools there.
And many of them who can come over here to visit.
So I'm going to be taking them.
You finished. I will be taking a lot of them to that museum.
Fantastic.
Well, what a great way to end.
Well, thank you so much.
Thank you.
It's been just a little bit.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.